Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in,
we have discussed
thus far
and have researched
the
types of people and the and the
points of criteria
that make fasting obligated on an
individual. We've also discussed the
exemptions from that travel,
illness, old age,
unusual
hardship,
breastfeeding,
and pregnancy, etc. We've discussed
all of these things.
Now we will discuss a very important
point and I really want everyone to pay
close attention to this issue
and that is when we say feed a poor
person for each day that you miss
or the experation of feeding a poor
person. What is meant by that and what
are the parameters of that? The author
says
the amount of
the amount of food that a person must
feed a poor person in order for it to
act as an expeation.
He cites just one narration here for us.
He says,
This narration has been collected
by
his.
So in this narration
was narrated that in his lifetime he was
unable to fast one year.
As we know Malik is one of the last
companions to pass away, right? Do you
guys remember how old he was when he
passed away?
120. Yes. And so he was very old. And
here we have as he was getting up there
in age, one year he was unable to fast.
And so
he
gathered 30 poor people
and made for them a dish called the
and he had them eat their fill.
Okay, this is the narration.
We need to look into a couple of things
here to unpack.
Number one,
he gathered 30 poor people.
He didn't feed the same one 30 times. He
gathered 30. Number two, he didn't give
them money. He made food for them and
fed them. Number three, he fed them a
dish called and this is important and
will come into play in a moment
[Arabic recitation]
Number four, did he do this at the
beginning of Ramadan or at the end of
Ramadan?
These questions are what we need to take
from this narration.
Number
one, he gathered 30 poor people
because the this is most most
this is most
or this is the closest to the the the
exact ruling that is mentioned by Allah
in the verse we mentioned. mentioned
that the verse is verse 184 in
that Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says
these three words
that the experation is feeding of a poor
person.
the feeding of a poor person.
So what the companions understood from
that is feeding here is feeding a meal.
It's not just giving them a you know a
date. It is feeding them a full meal, an
average meal.
Number two, he says mskin
in the singular
and this is for each day that a person
misses.
In another recitation of this same
verse,
feeding of poor people in the plural.
So the companions understood from this
that for each day is feeding one poor
person and for multiple days feeding
poor people. Another
thing
is that
he made for them a dish called
is essentially
meat usually it's not chicken or
poultry it's meat. So it is usually lamb
or goat meat and bread, right? And when
we look at the
diet or when we look at the dishes
that the Arabs and specifically the
companions
ate and we were to categorize this dish
at what is this a delicacy? Is this like
our caviar or is this, you know,
run-of-the-mill
French fries for us? The answer is
it's right in the middle. It's neither a
delicacy
nor is it the food of the poor or a
lowerend food. This is a respectable
meal that is an average meal. As a
matter of fact, it is probably above
average. The prophet Sam
compared to a he said
he says and the
virtue that is holds over the rest of
women all the other women is the
virtue that this dish at holds over
all the other types of food. So it is
not just in the middle but it is of the
higher end. This is important
because
if I were to come and implement that
today,
would it be sufficient for me to give
someone a pound of rice?
Just rice. Just a bag of rice. And give
them a bag of rice. Is that good enough?
Not even close. This is not miskin.
What about give them a half pound of of
of lentils? Just dry lentils. Here
you go. Right.
Or what about if I just gave him 10
bucks? I had a guy ask me last night
that the kaf is supposed to be $3.
Tell me what you can buy for $3 here in
America.
What meal is $3?
Can you buy a candy bar for your son for
$3?
No.
This is some kind of skimping cheapkate
fet, you know, thing that's from like
1970s. It it was $3. What happened?
Yeah. Well, 50 years passed by, right?
No, the kaf is not just the companions
had money. They had physical money. They
had currency.
They could
who could have given some money to a
poor person and let him go. It's not
their time and our time is
dissimilar in the sense that at that
time they gave each other food and in
our time we have money and they didn't
have money. They had currency. As a
matter of fact, their currency was much
more valuable and much more plentiful
than our currency.
Right? So this is not considered to be a
kaf a kaf
as the verse clearly states and as the
companions clearly understood and this
is just one evidence because the name of
the book is what el wajis
the the summary it's a book that is a
summarized book there are dozens of
evidences for this. But this is a very
clear evidence. So the author mentions
it and that is that
the companions understood the verse. The
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
understood the verse that you are to
feed a poor person a full meal.
Now it doesn't specify the age of the
poor person.
And children take the ruling of their
parents
in in social status. They take the
ruling of their parents. So let's say
you
have an impoverished family of five,
right, with little kids that eat solid
food. The com the the scholars mention
that the child has to be at least of age
to eat solid food. and you were to have
them for dinner and have them eat that
is five days experation. The point is a
full meal. That is as Allah mentions
elsewhere in all experations
from the median of what you feed your
own family.
Whatever your median is,
the medium status meal that you would
feed your own family, that is what is
done for expeation.
It is your responsibility
to feed these poor people. One of the
big problems that we face today
is taking away and hollowing out the
connections that Islam made between the
wealthy and the poor.
So for instance, I will go online, I
will find some mega website that does
kaf. I'll put in my, you know, person
will put in his credit card number and
then just forget about it. This does not
help our community.
The point of this command of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is that the rich and
the poor interact with each other.
Interact with each other in good will
and this sews seeds of good will.
The essence of this is that each one of
us is responsible to either fast or pay
his kafar. not pay his kafar or perform
his kafar and if we are unable to fast
then we will know a poor person or poor
people that are Muslim because all
obligatory this is a principle you could
take it as a general rule all obligatory
feeding or all obligatory
charity zak anything that is
obligate atory it is for a Muslim
non-Muslim can get that which is which
is nonobligatory
right but zak
freeing a slave whatever any of these
things that you find in the Quran
experations recourse this is always
for a believer the the poor person
must be a Muslim
and that you personally feed this poor
person
had time as a governor
and
was one of the most major of figures in
Iraq.
Yet he
even though he was in
essentially a position of royalty
when he did not fast he personally
brought 30 poor people to eat his food
that he made for them. That is the point
of these kinds of experations. It is to
make bonds of goodwill between the
rich and the poor. the strong and the
weak in order that we all share
common experiences of goodwill with
one another. Not just putting in a
number in a computer and and and
forgetting about it. Right? Now if you
could imagine for instance here in our
community if we wanted to implement this
we say for instance
well let's say the masid
were to have a program
where if you give the kafar to us and
specify that it is a kafar
then we will ensure that it's final
, it arrives at its final destination
in the form of food for a poor person of
the same community. Would it be
permissible to do that? Yes. In this
case, it would be permissible for
us to use that kind of medium. And this
would this would fall into the realm of
alwa, right? you're entrusting
the masid or
whatever to do that and that goes the
same goes for and the same goes for zak
but the essence of these things is that
the personally
do it right and if a person were to say
well I don't know any poor people it
doesn't mean a poor person that is
living in rags in a a cardboard box
under the bridge. That is not what is
meant by a poor person necessarily. A
mskin in the language of the Quran is
anyone who does not make enough money in
his year
to cover all of his expenses.
This is a poor person, right? if we
were to take their entire income for the
year, their entire salary, and just
going off of that,
they're unable in the society in which
they live to complete that with that
income for a year. They fall short a
month. They fall short they have to they
have to make do from other places,
right? from other avenues in order to
make do whether they need to sell
things, they need to find extra work,
they need to whatever it is, this is
considered to be a poor person,
right? And I would wager that a good 20
30% of many Americans today in
general are living that. They're
having that difficulty. They need
additional help whether it's government
help or they need and so if any person
is on welfare, if any person is on food
stamps, if any this person is eligible
for zaka, this person is eligible for
alaf.
You feed them a meal.
The simplest form of this would get a
takeout meal of 10 $15 and hand it to
the person. The best form of it is to
invite those who are your neighbors,
those who are your friends, those who
you know from the masid to your home to
eat in this, right? Or for instance
our here there will be a
percentage of those who attend who will
fit the fit the definition of a mskim
whether it be one family or two or
three. probably if if you were to do
onear or a part of anar half or a
quarter, this would probably be enough
for your kaf for the entire month. But
the point is is that these things are to
be practiced personally. That's the
whole idea. It's not just to give money
away. Giving money, anybody can do that.
That's the easiest thing for people who
are living in excess. The difficult
thing is giving time, giving energy,
you know,
making food yourself or going out of
your way or reaching out of your comfort
zone of of people that you're familiar
with in order to in order to bridge
those gaps and sew those seeds of
goodwill within the same community. And
always
charities are spent in the person's
community, their immediate community and
most importantly within their family if
at all possible. So if you have family
members that fit this criteria of moss,
they are the first person that you would
that you would feed before going out.
And when we say family members, meaning
those that live with you here. If you
have family members overseas, but you
have people that are not family members
that fit that bill here, the ones here
take precedence over the ones overseas.
Why? Why is that? To sew seeds of good
will between the rich and the poor.
That's the whole point of this is that
we are all one. We're all the same. Yes,
Allah has given virtue to some over
others. That's how the world works.
That doesn't mean one is better than the
other, the other is less than the other.
But it does mean that if we leave too
many gaps, shan will always fill in the
[Arabic recitation]
I'm doing that. How are you?